[Music]
Hey
hope you guys had an amazing weekend it
is love coding bur Haigh bruh how are
you how are you doing let go we are
going to review my quarterback rankings
as it comes to stepdads we are going to
talk some whoa big offseason whoa we
have a lot of new audio I'm waiting for
the music to go down but to be honest I
know that you guys are seeing whether
it's YouTube headline or it's the iPod
or the podcast whatever it is Michael
Vick and I have decided that instead of
doing 20 minutes of us talking and then
Michael Vick it was such an enjoyable
conversation that I don't want to wait
any long yeah I don't want to I'm saving
you your thumbs from having to just skip
skip skip skip scrapes right to Michael
Vick let's just get to it I mean at one
point in the middle of this I looked at
him and I went can I talk to you about
prison and like I had told you
beforehand that I wanted to and you were
I was nervous but he was down what I
told you is exactly what was true which
is that like I think a lot of people are
fascinated by his time in prison that if
he's willing to talk about it it would
be really interesting I just don't know
if I personally would have the balls to
look him in the eye and be like hey can
we talk about this but you did and he
was like yeah sure and then at the end
he calls me the homie so here is Mike
Vick enjoy this interview and then we'll
be back with the quarterback rankings
and whoa big offseason right after this
[Music]
the West Coast feel hey yeah you like it
I would love to hear what makes spit on
it so it was pretty good
the thing about you notice when people
start to freestyle your first thought is
okay how much of that was written down
ahead of time right right yeah yeah cuz
I mean a lot of it is probably but what
I appreciate about Nate is Nate will go
like look at things in the studio and
that's when you know yeah yes if he can
pick some like off the wall up yeah got
a couple yeah I got my water up when she
walks in and make it just shut up yeah
we got michael vick in the building i I
told him that the beat was gonna be good
he said maybe I'll freeze he was nice
I'll put together yes sound good
33 percent I can I can write some to it
I can't freestyle to it see you're a
writer yeah man are you on our side
neither did I put the thoughts on down
on paper are you like on the team bus
head up against the window just putting
them down yeah it all depends on where
yeah what so have you ever been in the
studio with like people that could
really do it because I have to imagine
you got invited to some set I can't
remember I was sitting down like for a
whole session yeah like somebody putting
a song together I think I've been in
there when guy was like it was just
messing around
yeah but you know legit rappers they
wasn't known yeah we talking screen
stages some boys from the hood you you
from the homies you know what's funny
though is like if you said someone's
name they'd be like damn mike vick
really appreciate that one time he was
in the studio with me yeah well no man
never really spent time in industry I
probably have just came good luck right
now I can't even imagine I walked into a
studio one time and Allen Iverson was
there and he said that my boy looked
like keifa and Horne
yeah well the greatest moments Oh for
real yeah cuz like this for him payin
attention kids like you walked into a
studio and like music was bumping an a I
turned around and I'm like a 15 year old
kid in Philly I gotta grow up on Jordans
I grew up on Iverson like oh yeah yeah I
mean I know you got a real moment now
yeah he really mean
I'm from the same neighborhood so we
always see each other back end you know
back home and off seasons I saw that I
saw his football clips started making
the rounds again and then everyone
started saying recently I think you
might opposes someone his birthday yeah
a game a game he chose the right sport
though he chose the right split I mean I
was in 190 soaking wet holy crap in his
prime in his prime yeah he looked good
he looked better on the basketball court
your life right now man you're doing the
TV thing I know that you're still doing
your speaking tour you're working with
the American flag football league yeah
had their big Championships gonna be
this weekend how's life good man shout
out to my wife GI food my kids Jaden
landing with tears when your son Michael
Vick jr. Wow everybody's doing good man
life is great you got a junior now yeah
I gotta join you started all over
keeps us young congratulations yeah man
just that and got the speaking tour to
be putting together playing a little
flag football to stay in shape
yeah yeah the championships this week so
very interested to see how that's gonna
go
does Michael Vick ever get out of shape
like it's gotta be hard for you guys I
mean I can get out of shape you know if
I go like a month and a half just eaten
damn cheese fries yeah you know just
going ham for no reason I can do that
with a wife sometimes she she letting
you go fool I'm right there with it dude
I'm just saying cosign every time I see
you though I'm like you could play in
the NFL right now like I mean my god for
Zeke wise I don't never get out of place
I don't think you know I mean I mean to
my home but I'm physically gifted so
yeah yeah man so it don't take much like
20 20 push-ups 20 sit-ups and they you
know you're about to see some bulbs
that's crazy
I've seen Lobos ya know it ain't fair
man but no no it's very fair it's it's
nice man yes it's fair my world that's
all I'm saying cuz I remember when you
came to the Eagles you know you just
come from prison you go to the Eagles
and it was like
yeah like the Sun was there the arm was
there cannon I mean Kevin Cobb and I was
like get him out of here is victime
manly I believe Kevin was my boy man and
the thing I like about that whole
dynamic was that we complemented each
other we should put each other all the
way through like when I got hurt three
or four weeks in yeah keV stepped in I
supported him like it was a good
relationship and that's rare sometimes
for a quarterback room yeah it make
special E when somebody go down and
godsake their position oh dude you know
also think about this if let's say you
could have probably still been playing
backup quarterback in the NFL for five
six years but we know the truth and the
truth is is if it draining at training
camp your ball has more zip than the
starter yeah and then there's a little
bit issues in week two or three man yeah
I mean that was just too much of a
threat like I used to talk it over my
agent all the time we start we talk
about it just how like anywhere I went
it don't matter
the minute I step on the practice field
and start looking like you know what
people used to see yeah then it's like
to the crowd and the fans last thing you
want is if we won't Vic chant when
things not so it became a burden on me a
distraction and it kind of hindered my
career a little bit but actually always
tell my wife about that it's the truth
the truth is the truth behind it there's
a reason why the backup quarterbacks the
NFL and this is no sleight to them yeah
because they're probably helping out the
starting quarterback put the the Matt
jobs the Ryan Fitzpatrick's they're
non-threatening some quarterbacks don't
want a guy behind him that you know can
probably take their position or go in
and play as well as they can I mean is
that why you and then were able to work
out there cuz Ben was so confident in
itself Dave and it wasn't he's not
worried about anything like he
encouraged his thing when they made the
move to bring in Mason Rudolph
being wasn't upset about them bringing
their Mason Rudolph it was more so about
yeah we could that's a good pick but I'm
not going to win any time so we could
have used that
pickmonz on the receiver receiver so
wasn't about has never been about
who was behind him you know he always
keeps his head straightforward he's
gonna have to keep his head straight
forward the whole a B thing the Le'Veon
thing as someone that was in that locker
room what was I like to watch man I mean
it was specially because it was like
seeing the big three all over again when
you hear a comment
Irvin and Emmett but I mean what
happened this past offseason a B I'm the
whole mustache going to Oakland I mean
you know awful it's weird
you almost have to be in the locker room
to know like at the end of the day you
got a eight year veteran or six year
veteran a 11 year veteran and couldn't
seem to work together anymore
but it's a bunch of different moving
parts my guys won more money being
contracts the guys think he's open he's
not or
he's open you don't see him yeah yeah
yeah you know one guy want the ball way
more than maybe on a situation me
understand he's running back he's
getting abused each and every play
deserves get the guarantee that every
dime that that's coming to him and that
he still get you know for you know for
the services but yes it's just good to
see the Pittsburg Landing on your feet
and so on you landed on his feet and so
worked out for everybody
one of my favorite shows on TV is
Atlanta and with Donald Glover and and
and what they've reacted by the way oh
he's unbelievable hell of a musician too
it's Jay yeah you know he's in one of
the episodes
it ends with oh yeah Mike Vicks out here
racing paper eraser at the end one do
you actually raise people no okay
because I had Ted get me here and
getting said if you got 10,000 I'll race
anything yeah I heard that Ted still
young tick and fly I ain't racing nobody
from no amount of money because the
first thing that's gonna happen to me is
i'ma pull a hamstring gonna pull a groin
like I that was me you just know it yeah
I was confirmation last week when I was
practicing trying to get ready for the
flag football game yeah this weekend in
man a minute I bursted you felt it I
burst okay yeah
this but with that no I mean I imagine a
lot of people try to race you well now
it's like a common joke
Oh after the episode now I get it from
everybody try to race random people so I
mean what I'm gonna do is just I'm gonna
pick and choose who I raised so you know
guy walk up he little flabby he may get
he think it's a joke okay that's less
getting in 400 real quick gotcha
forty yards I can do that without
stretching take his money room
oh so you will you just want to pick
your opponent yeah yeah when picking to
lose my opponent like boxing all right
so if I walked up on you real quick just
just tell me the truth
yeah I'm gonna take you I would take you
down I wouldn't do it I would I would
say me and then I'd let someone else
slide in real quick oh it's funny as I
typed in my quick into Google and three
different articles popped up Kyler
Murray is the most exciting quarterback
since Mike Vick Lamar Jackson is the
most exciting quarterback since Mike
Vick every yeah who else
deshaun Watson is the most exciting
every time and a guy that can move comes
the NFL Draft we're going back to your
draft which is now 18 years ago yeah
thankfully soda are any of them like if
you had to pick from all of them the one
that reminds you of you because they all
get compared to you but it's one of them
actually the closest to you man up until
last year I would say Lamar because
Lamar's like he has what it takes but
when I watched calimary even though he's
in a different system then Lamar and
pretty much the system that he he's in
now it was assistant Lee he was in at
Oklahoma so it's gonna look exactly the
same but the hash is just a little
tighter yeah so that's the only concern
can he do it you know in a more compact
space place that's the guy he's the guy
that that can just wiggle and just you
know his statue and not being able to be
seen by defenders and what he brings to
the table I also think they're proud I
think you're a lick like that flick
no he's very accurate yeah he has a big
hand wraps around the ball for his size
he's a you know he's a big man for the
size of that make sense you know he's
not being a statue but he he's wide you
know he got big hands he you know I mean
just well put together yeah and good
enough to I think keep the offensive
coordinators up all night I was talking
to a few guys on that team and I said I
said you were there for Josh Rosen
rookie you're there for collar how's he
looking so far and they said not only
does he have the x-factor of running but
when he walks in the huddle man you just
kind of feel a little bit laggy and that
matters no say that the kid knows too
often is better than anybody and I talk
to people to check on that quote and
they agree I know it's validation for
that I mean I spoke to some people so he
really has a good understanding of the
offense and why would you change
anything never you know I think it was
you know what it's like to be put into a
system that you just why change anything
plug them right back into the same
system make it easy teaching for her
foot well you can teach your quarterback
and we can take an offense and he can
coach it without the coaches coaching
and that's the biggest plasti ever there
have been a lot of documentaries about
you Bleacher Report did one as well
but if there was ever to be a feature
film with actors and you could choose
who played Michael Vick who would you
pick I don't know man couple guys out
there me you know yeah I want to hear
the list I don't know of course
everybody gonna say Denzel he's the
number one every day means once you've
become actors they're probably gonna
tell son he was the one in black
Klansmen gotta see him yeah you gotta be
a younger guy man it can't be a guy what
if they were like we have it Michael B
Jordan slayed it to play it won't work
no it won't work I don't know a lot of
actors names I know when I see them got
you know any names so you give me a line
in the back and say yeah that guy and
that guy can point them out yeah man has
anyone ever approached you about
something like that no but it'll
probably happen
so yeah you know you gotta let time
elapsed when of course you know you have
a moment in time where you know it's
unforgettable of course and then you do
a bunch of things in between I mean I
remember well I remember the moment
where I was when you got signed to the
Eagles really I was in a newsroom in
Hastings Nebraska because I was a
general assignment reporter yeah and I
this is before there's like 2,000 what
nine ten something like that 2009 and I
remember I'm at a computer and at a news
computer there's like a little alert so
here and it was like the AP is reporting
the Eagles have signed Michael Vick and
I lost my [ __ ] I lost my [ __ ] I mean it
was the coolest yeah it was for me I
didn't think I would go to Philly I I
didn't want to play for a team where I
would have to be a backup but uh it
worked out it was a lot a lot of things
going on in my life at the time yeah
yeah it was kind of a blessing to land a
Philly
did you think when after after your time
in prison were you confident that a team
would sign you or were you even
concerned that it would happen I mean
you always concerned that things might
not go the way that you wanted to go
because of you know public opinion or
public perception but at the same time I
was still I was I felt like it was it
would happen
yeah in the right and at the right time
the right moment my agent he always made
me feel good about it you know as far as
the optimism yeah other than that you
don't need me you feeling known so you
know I just didn't want to come out and
have to work that construction job that
I had to work for you know two or three
years man where you were going to pay
the bills what were you doing when you
come home from prison federal prison you
have to have a job ya know so you know
me edges in scramble mode trying to find
it yes so what were you doing well I
worked construction for two weeks and
then I started working at the Boys &
Girls Club Wow so what kind of
construction like my dad did like
refrigeration and stuff like that you
were doing what laying roads and now we
was building a hand get the airport man
and you know I think the first day I was
nailed went through my fingers something
man
it's making me kill myself out here yeah
and we're people that I was trying to
duck duck and dodge the manager where
people walk up mind they're like they're
like the one site manager looking around
and where's Vic over there land up under
the shade yeah I'm in the shade man
drinking was there ever a moment though
we're so long bye they're like are you
know you know I got a lot of double
chicks though like guys like you know is
that really him
but yeah it was cool it was it was it
was humbling yeah it was experience to
get up every day at 5:30 had to be there
6:30 and I just see how hard guys work
to make sure that other people in the
world I secured I had with what they
need to function I've had a conversation
recently about like purpose me and Nate
were talking about he after nipsey died
he kind of realized like I need to stand
for something big yeah when you go
through the humbling process you go
through that amount of time we have so
much to think about like uh you were a
top athlete so I know that you had
discipline like I know that you had
focus on that yeah but did it even
change that up even more so like that it
even heightened it to the next level as
far as focus just like also like when
you wake up did it change oh yeah well
it changed you know once everything was
taken away from me it's like I started
to think about all the things that I
could have done better that I didn't pay
attention to that mattered the most
so yeah he's talking about waking up
with a sense of purpose it's like okay
when I wake up tomorrow I would wake up
and i'ma get my workout in earlier you
know and not at 8 o'clock I'm gonna get
it at 7 o'clock so I have an album
between there's some extra things in
between time and just you know wanted to
have priorities in order
and I have a you know foggy mind yeah
yeah cuz you know you put too much on
your plate man and then you know it's
it's not a easy task to you know make
sure that you get things accomplished I
want to do have my day well thought out
and you know the sense of purpose at the
end is if I look back and say I
accomplished everything I wanted to
accomplish whether
being small then I do it hopefully I'm
saying yes at the end of the day the
thing you're just talking about like
distractions I just read this book where
Napoleon the French leader yeah would
tell his people under him don't bring me
letters until they're three weeks old
because I have a lot of people that are
telling me they got a lot of important
stuff going on but really if I wait
three weeks it'll probably figure it
something out right because he had to
step away yeah and I look at like cell
phones now in media now and all that and
then I think about someone like you and
how many people are probably hitting you
up on a daily basis yeah show up to this
do this yeah like in a way like you got
to separate all that [ __ ] right you got
to vet out the process man it's just
like don't overwhelm yourself because so
many things could become enticing
material can become in tighten monetary
to become entice yeah next thing you
know you losing out on quality time with
your family you know you might you know
just getting getting involved in
something just don't make sense
yeah and because he was doing it for the
wrong reasons so and I think once so
many other step back and I think that's
why it's important now like trying to
run a lot of things past my wife and she
was she thinking she's at that rock yeah
he knows out in the the people who were
close to me who can help me make a
decision like on the spot or if I got to
make a decision and I got to really
think it through yeah and didn't weigh
out the pros and the cons I like that I
like that part of you know my life and
the structure that's in it now I'm sure
when you were growing up you were like
I'm just gonna do oh yeah I mean up
until like two years ago I was like I'm
just gonna do yeah and I was still
playing and you know just you know
recently retired and I'm gonna do
everything that comes my way because
it's about branding and it's about you
know continue to keep things going and
you know I got a family to take care
yeah all things aren't good can I ask
you a question about prison is that okay
yeah good okay because me that's like my
biggest fear is is it's I've it's
whether it be a what going stepping
aside it's like the likes well sure
there's that but it's like movies and
all that stuff
was it I mean I'm sure you were scared
too like absolutely yeah no doubt if you
look serious you put your games you just
keep your head down the whole time to
game face on when you first walk in
really
I won't tell people what I did when I
first went in in order to calm my nerves
or in order to make just you know my
bravado yeah because I might write about
it in another book that I read yeah cuz
if I'm you I'm thinking I got a target
on my back already
cuz I'm yeah it was just brilliant I
kind of came in and like a weird time
with the day you know it was at
lunchtime oh oh so I just have to walk
right into the cafeteria he's like what
a chow hall which is what I was looking
around like Oh what do I sit you know
you got over here section over there
you're like if I sit in that section am
i yeah you don't know where you're
welcome this yeah I just I just had to
man up man damn no I just when I wanted
to sit I didn't care about who was
looking at me or you know making it yeah
assumption of you know what I look like
and what sizing me up right I cared
about nothing but I is you know funny
stories about the things that I I didn't
like the first two weeks just to make
sure I secure myself yeah language
street door and come from that yeah you
know I lived in it but I didn't do it
you were the athlete you were protect
yeah yeah when you're when you're the
athlete in the community they protect a
but when I went the 11 worlds like they
just oh you and no building with 50 455
guys and yeah my dream for you is that
someone would be like you know I want
that desert and then someone else stands
up it goes don't be Michael and you're
like like that's my dream like that's
what my thing is bro yeah appreciate it
I've got like I'm a big file contain now
I held it there Wow
did you like you had to leave and feel
more sure of who you were after our
process like that yeah why I was just
stronger I think the relationships and
the people that I met and people I came
in contact with
you know I got a lot a lot out of it
did you resume I I learned to play chess
I've read so many books yeah I came out
of much better person much stronger
person and you know still a little
broken but you know it was it was room
for me to be repaired and I made so I
kept that space because I couldn't do
everything while I was in there right
I couldn't soak in everything because
that's not the place you don't you don't
see enough visually you can you only
envision you know use your imagination
so I do you know remain vulnerable and
you know a couple of different areas and
then that was for my family to help me
fix and yeah I for that would be fixing
my mom and and the people who was there
for me oh man like I'm sure those
relationships got so strong oh man yeah
cuz it was just all it was all
communication yeah it was nothing in the
physical it wasn't any touching there
wasn't any you know physical kisses on
the cheek or you know goodbyes you know
all that was just like you know
everything was visual I mean I wouldn't
get out of bed like if I when you got
out I wouldn't get out of bed for a week
I'd be like we're cuddling for a week
we're gonna order some food we cut off
about a week yeah so if you went to
McDonald's right afterwards yeah I think
I went straight to McDonald's yeah when
I got I was like 3:30 in the mom I think
I couldn't I couldn't wait I remember
this being and I'm camping outside like
I'm never going to housing it was was
like it's real like being able to open
the door yeah it was just the little
things that you took for granted
yeah right dude it's funny cuz now I
think about a night those memories are
like gone it's another lifetime
yeah it's another lifetime ago but still
like I should try to reflect on that as
much as I can it's hard it's hard
because you you've been there done that
of course but I'm just saying the small
things and I really do they make a
difference from time it is while that
like you could close your eyes and you
could be 8 year old Mike Vick you can
close your eyes and be 18 mile my Vick
and the thing is is like we don't feel
the same pain that we did back then yeah
but it defined who we are
yeah and you kind of have to that's why
I always hear like it's not losses it's
lesson right that's it
and and like you can impart wisdom to
your children that I could never in part
because of the things you've seen right
I can go watch this movie we'll see if
it's accurate yeah you can really share
and that's correct that's experience
yeah I could see somebody about to make
a mistake of saying something that that
means it's cool to just be able to draw
from those experiences man yeah there's
a power to yeah
the reason we're able to do this
interview is because of the American
flag football league yeah there when
this comes out it will have been the
weekend before so right we're talking on
a Thursday it's happening this weekend
and I have been told that you guys went
out there last year and said we're
taking on a bunch of flag football guys
we're gonna be able to smoke these dudes
and then the athletes in this league
though it sounds like it's a bunch of
Wes Welker and Julian Edelman I believe
apart totally different look for my team
Nishat and what it was last year and a
different feel and approach like I can
honestly say last year I was 100%
confident that we were win yeah but
didn't put in the hard work I didn't
want to learn the rules right what it
took to win a flag for gain of these
guys are professionals that we have to
realize I understand they know how to
play flag football right a few ask me
if we land up 28 NFL teams and they all
had their own best of their seven
there's seven guys their best seven guys
playing offense against one of these
teams yeah they wouldn't win not at 100
the NFL teams in FL teams would not win
there's no way so if guys are good the
rules are different if I put Davante
Adams and DeAndre Hopkins and I had
Patrick mahomes back there and I had
Zach Ertz a tight end and Kelsey yet the
other one not happening now you I mean
it looked good on paper
yeah but the way you have to play in the
rules and it'll be tough for those guys
well and those are the that's the best
of the best clean with the crowd yeah
you know what those guys are gonna try
to do to combat that is it's amazing
it's crazy to see that the seven or
seven game
flag is really taking on a different you
know type of feel the thing that I
appreciate about you saying that is so
many of these leagues it's like a flash
of the pan but for one of the greatest
quarterbacks to ever play to leave and
go there better than any NFL player you
don't hear that not better I'm saying
for the laughs but no one's gonna look
at the big three and go any three NBA
players wouldn't have a chance against
these no no no no they wouldn't because
because just because of technique and
pulling flags and yeah you know having
to transition from office to defense and
what it takes to really focus in on a
flag and grab it yeah I couldn't do it
I've seen some of the best athletes and
I play with I guess we couldn't do it we
can we was knocked out the first round
Wow and we had a really good thing yeah
you know I was a little salty if you see
the interviews after the game I was a
poor sport and and that's the one thing
I do regret about lash I'm never you'll
never see me playing flag football again
and oh you was mad and you know more so
like anything that has a dual football
if I look like I'm so competitive I'm
sure you know it's like you don't feel
like a loser but it's somewhat
embarrassing and that's why I was always
happy when we lost the game I kept my
helmet on yeah walk in the locker room
you don't have to show facial expression
and I see doing a postgame press
conference but man I'm telling you I
still have fun days and I'm back again
for another year yeah that's a big deal
have fun with it man we the last time I
talked to you you're in Atlanta for the
Super Bowl and to watch you walk around
Atlanta is unbelievable like it's it's
godlike [ __ ] yeah is I'm assuming right
now Julio like I know that Matt Ryan
when he signed his contract they're like
he's the face of Atlanta everybody yeah
to me Julio is the face of the Atlanta
Falcons yeah and I wonder like what kind
of respect her pride you have for him
and kind of what he's added to the
franchise that you really helped you
know we start on you know I think Julio
just continues to help you know with
with the coach of the people love him
you know he's a dynamic player he's one
of the best
playing the game today never gives a
less than 100 you say so you have to
appreciate that and I think you know
Julio can walk around the city of an
April he can go anywhere he want it
finally bunch of other guys on the team
who can too but Julio is well respected
and you know he's a he's a five-star
general what's your talk oh just take on
the homes oh man just because I'm
already ruling the crowd and one of the
best I've ever seen
yeah no doubt I mean and he's only
played one full season I have to
throwing that no-look pass I'll just
tell everybody to have the balls to do
that in the in the game
yeah like live action when to us we
looking at it and it's looking like it's
moving in slow motion but knowing that
everything is like enhanced on the field
and for him to be able to do that and I
think the game was close
yeah that's what makes it so so crazy
that he even pulled that off it was him
to do it yeah for him to do that man
that moment just solidified his um this
progression and you're one of your two
and then just have really good of a
football player here so I'm excited
about the kid I can't wait to watch him
this year it's gonna be exciting season
it is gonna be an amazing season yeah
probably talk about the Cleveland Browns
way more than I talked about anybody
this year so that's your squad right now
I mean I'm just watching really close
when you look if you talk about teams on
paper yeah I don't think there's a
better one to wide receiver combo maybe
in the history of the game
then Odell Jarvis and what I mean is the
way they complement each other the
overall speed the quick of Jarvis in Joe
ku the running backs they have Baker
that offensive line Myles Garrett Denzel
Ward they spent some money Reedy winds
greedy Williams they just got got some
good linebackers you know what it feels
like it feels like it's gonna let us
down cuz that's you know what he always
happens I was thinking about that last
night you were on the dream team yeah it
was like when there's that much hype it
can disappoint it's gonna come down to
coaching okay it'll come down to
coaching night the one thing I would say
is you know John Dorsey is one of the
greatest
well one of the greatest general
managers ability spent a lot of time in
New England won some Super Bowls and
built the Kansas City roster before and
he took over and now he took the
Cleveland Browns in just two years and
got him looking like they can do
something in 2019 so I think he got the
right coaching staff and probably sure
that that was probably the easiest thing
to do that's easier than picking players
so he got a good staff plugged the
players in the right positions man and
let him go
but Baker's a baller yeah man if you
look looked back in into 2017 man when I
was on Fox when I first started I was
always giving Baker Mayfield shoutouts
and it was Acts who we thought was the
top guys you know I thought him and
Lamar would be yeah you know to the top
and then sort of top two quarterbacks
and then I patching my home's just came
out of nowhere
so and turned out to be a really good
class I did really good class it's
turned out to be a really good time yeah
all the time
always have a good conversation you do
homie I think alway and hold on I'm
gonna let that last comment just really
sit there for a sec hey cuz I called my
guys the homies and I called the 33%
yeah I know they appreciate you better
[ __ ] slide in two Vic's mentions and
hit him up on Twitter and into the
ground and let him know that he is the
man you're welcome back anytime oh man
if you want a freestyle hey I give you
some next time man next time fool out of
myself man with the white night like
maybe why you do that you know you know
rapper Mike Vick that was the Camaro
he's dead okay bring it next time
appreciate your homie
the homie ingmar michael vick and he
said when he comes back he will write a
rap for us yes he did say that that's
guaranteed it as we say at the poker
table that's binding yeah it's ruled out
yeah he has to do it it's an oral
contract that you struck with it what
was the vibe you got just of watching
Michael Vick in the office to like the
vibe I always get is he's very
understated and that so many people
react so big to him that he's always
just the chillest guy there is he yeah
he was very nice to me he was very nice
to everyone that he seemed to interact
with I'm
his wife yeah I met some of the people
that work with him I think someone was
his manager just seems like a nice
grounded crew of people around us which
is always nice to see with athletes that
they're not like rolling with some crazy
entourage that's just like feeding crazy
ego he seems like he's got a nice team
around him then they're there doing good
work and we recorded that interview last
week and as you could tell we were we
got help from that from the American
flag football league and I hope their
league does awesome I got a chance to
talk to Jeff Lewis their founder and
he's a character and they really believe
that flag football league is growing and
the one thing that all of the through
line of all that yes all those
interviews and you were talking to all
the flag football people off-camera they
all are 100% convinced that a team of
NFL athletes can't beat the best non NFL
flag football team it kind of agreed
with them yeah he was like yeah we can't
beat these guys it's just a bunch of
Edelman's and like Amendola scrappy
Welker is running around that Vince
Papale ease in a way that entire life to
get their opportunity and they're
[ __ ] good apparel and it made sense
though the way they were describing it
where it's like when you're in the NFL
you're built to you know absorb contact
and the flag football is like oh I just
need to be 100 percent speed yes it's
just DeSean Jackson losing 20 pounds and
then just you know crushing out there I
would say if I saw a bunch of little
white guys beating a bunch of NFL
players you know what thought I'd have
in my head mmm whoa-ohh season so it is
time for the big reveal it is
[Applause]
big offseason let's go
alright so whoa big offseason in Burt
you we kind of went through some
together but I don't know which ones
you're picking for the in Berta fine
right this is a we count them down from
five to one they're not necessarily in
an order they're kind of just like we've
concocted a listed yeah yeah okay but
number five this this amazing Jets quote
that was all over social but I just
wanted to discuss and get your take on
it I think I've seen this Jets wide
receiver coach Sean Jefferson okay oh
yeah yeah yeah he's talking about have
you cursed on this podcast yet I try to
avoid it on so that it has more import
when I do this I'm just reading verbatim
a quote so don't get mad at me he's
talking about his man Sam darn 'old your
man loved Arnold excuse my french when I
say this but he's a [ __ ] dude he's a
[ __ ] dude with a [ __ ] arm and he's
accurate as [ __ ] whoa big offseason
Wiemers coach Sean Jefferson all over it
what was he asked that prompted that
also I want to know like he's a [ __ ]
dude it's so good like I've never heard
like we've we've all heard he used to do
dude with a [ __ ] oh yeah I just
I am I sort of like my brain of slang
and lingo I'd be like he's a [ __ ]
awesome dude or he's a [ __ ] shitty
dude or he's a [ __ ] chill dude I put
on adjectives before [ __ ] blank dude
I've said that a billion times in my
life but I've never just been like that
dude he's a [ __ ] dude I want to know
like what that means and his what you
just said to I'd also like to know how
long he said the word dude seven years
because I think the longer the dude huh
he is a do and then did he yeah did he
liquid you he's a dude [ __ ] dude also
it's really interesting because there's
missing a ton of adjectives
he's a effing dude and with an effing
arm yeah he's got a [ __ ] arm but he's
he got a big arm does he have a strong
arm like he's just a dude with an arm
again yeah if he had said like he's got
a [ __ ] cannon arm we'd be like right
okay that is the thing I can wrap my
brain around but it like he's got a
[ __ ] arm I will say this though
abouts and Arnold
everyone that's around him loves him
mm-hmm last year when he threw an
interception against Miami one of his
receivers came out and like stood up for
him and was like we wouldn't even be in
this game if it wasn't for him Le'Veon
Bell is posting random photos with him
all the time on his IG stories coaches
are coming out one of the reasons Joe
Douglas said he took the giant the Jets
GM job was because of Sam darn Alton he
is a [ __ ] dude I don't know if you did
this on purpose or not but you saying
that levian is putting him on Instagram
that's a will big offseason haven't so
late did you know that levy ons putting
a dartle all over the IG that it those
are many many was tiny whoa but I I feel
like I want a t-shirt that says like
darn 'old 14 on the back and on the
front just says he's a [ __ ] dude with
a [ __ ] arm and he's accurate as [ __ ]
the t-shirt should say he's a [ __ ]
dude on the front and on the back it
says with a [ __ ] harm or I would take
one that's a mathematical equation that
says [ __ ] dude plus [ __ ] our
family plus accurate as [ __ ] equals yeah
I think that's all that's one of the
best that will be up at the end of the
offseason for quote of the off season
especially if Donald like you know is a
world beater this year they win 11 or 12
games and then it's like that becomes
the rallying cry this was a mini woe
that I don't think is gonna make your
list Earl Thomas talked about Lamar
Jackson and said blockbuster like that's
a cool way but a coach going he's an F
and dude with an effing arm so great
yeah
number four two words Phil Weiser oh my
god did you see the pictures the amount
of people hitting up the left ko show
account with Phil Rivers rock and a
visor but like very specifically a
LaDainian Tomlinson visor oh that's what
you think of right oh that's what me oh
my god Chargers visor like is there
anything else in your brain besides that
yeah well you know I think that everyone
looks cooler with a visor just like I
think everyone looks faster with
dreadlocks okay because they have a
trail but with a visor it's like when
people wear sunglasses just you're
cooler I can't see your eyes this is
what I'm always thinking about because
if you'll notice I mean I play tennis as
many weekends as possible with you know
time permitting with a child now but I
almost always wear some
because I'm such a baby like as soon as
there's a little bit of Sun observe and
then you watch like Wimbledon in the
French Open they never are wearing
sunglasses quarterbacks if I can't see
your eyes that's a massive advantage
right away it is so like if Philip
Rivers if he can master that kind of
like look one way but squint the other
way you know it turn his head one way
and he can do these kind of no-look
passes if that's even a 5% advantage
it's huge the coolest athletes I think
in the NFL are playing football have
worn visors LaDainian is a great example
part of the reason I love Brian Dawkins
was he wore the visor I'm pretty sure
edy Reid were the visor too but also I
think about the replacements if you
remember there was that one dude on the
team that was like a safety but you
never heard him talk and he was like a
real convict he wore a visor it is it's
like this shroud of secrecy that adds to
it but I don't know if it's gonna stick
with rivers I don't know if it's an
actual thing or if it was just like a
training camp whoa
if it's if he comes out and goes I'm
tired of these [ __ ] watching my
eyes mm-hmm yeah and the other thing I'm
thinking about too with with these guys
wearing visors right like if you're the
sort of guy that that feels like you're
not as famous because you're wearing a
helmet all the time right that's always
been kind of a NACA like why are there
more famous NBA players than famous NFL
players right like is it because they're
wearing a helmet visor is like an extra
helmet on top of your helmet so maybe
Phil Rivers is like I've been in this
league forever I'm as famous as I
possibly could need to be now I'm ready
to get mine I'm gonna play even better
with this visor like he's not he's not
worried about the fame anymore he's
wondering his place what if on the
inside of the visor is the names of his
nine kids because he just forgets them
all or just the answers to the test it's
cheating on a quiz he's actually
watching Netflix yeah he's like I'm [ __ ]
it's like 15 you guys seem dead to me
it's great it's really good all right
number three number three I'm just a
huge fan of Melvin Ingram people the
podcast know that we love them just I
mean just watch the man play and it's
just a clinic on defense every time and
this is what he said this week quote
we're definitely going to win the Super
Bowl yes still ASAP any squad any place
that's what we're about okay so this is
a combination of two things
one I'm pretty sure that Melvin Ingram
has guaranteed a Super Bowl win the last
few years that's his move which is
amazing to go to it's a great well big
offseason because you're guaranteed for
nfl.com to go Ingram Ingram guarantees
chargers and Super Bowl also if you were
to ask any player of the 3500 players in
the NFL what's your goal this year
everyone's goal is to win the Super Bowl
he just keeps saying we're gonna do it
but the any squad any place a set after
every Chargers win he yells into the
camera ain't a [ __ ] any place we go and
he does this whole thing and it's just
it's so much [ __ ] energy but Melvin
Ingram is not afraid of anybody and I
love that he can guarantee this and like
his teammates would be like oh no no
Melvin can say that but we're not gonna
say that right yeah we're not gonna do I
think yeah everyone has that guy at work
or at that group of friends that says
the thing that everyone's thinking but
you're just glad that it's not you that
has to say it like if a friend of yours
you know like talk some [ __ ] to your
boss and you're like I'm glad he said
those words we're saying like I knew
people are fighting on a train and one
guy's like can you settle down and
you're like I wasn't gonna do that and
I'm glad too you did yeah that's Melvin
Ingram Melvin Ingram is that guy Melvin
Ingram genuinely believes at any time
that he is the strongest person in a
room and when he smacked me in the chest
at one time playing Ginga I'm not gonna
like so when we did the show last year
he literally was intimidating all of the
producers and all of the staff working
and he was allowed to cheat because no
one wanted to tell him that he would all
right like at one point we were like
Melvin stopped cheating off Melvin
Gordon he was like I'm not and they were
like sorry and it was we had video like
he was clearly looking over but
everyone's afraid of Melvin Ingram I
love that [ __ ] guy that's a good one
a Super Bowl guarantees a great well
Super Bowl guarantee yeah okay number
two Aaron Rodgers Oh is just the quote
that came out yeah so this was it was
kind of a teaser for the Mike Silver
article that came out about him and
LeFleur and their relationship all
dynamic it's an interesting read but I
think the quote was juicier than the
read it came out Friday article came out
Monday right and you should read the
article I mean there's some really
interesting stuff in there but the quote
is just juicy as hell
there's a lot of like we could go
conspiracy on it if we wanted to there's
a lot you could read into but anyway
I'll just read the quote quote I don't
think you want me to turn off 11 years
meaning 11 years in the league there's
stuff that not many people in the league
can do at the line that's not a humble
brag that's just a fact mm-hmm and
that's Rogers to Mike silver on
Lafleur's system not having a ton of
freedom at the line of scrimmage
this was a perfect whoa big offseason
because Pro Football Talk
I heard the Sun parted my take I heard
all these different places going it's
already start and look at this quote
Aaron Rodgers is already freaking out
with Matt Lafleur and then I read the
article today and the whole thing is
about how they're trying to be symbiotic
and how this was like one line where
he's like no we're gonna make this work
both of us like the entire article I go
Leflore and Rodgers are so cognizant of
how this could go bad and both of them
are admitting their own weaknesses like
Lafleur said multiple times this is this
very special quarterback he is very
intelligent it's not been assistant
because this is a Matt Lafleur system
that's been based on Kyle Shanahan so
what that means is so many plays are
going to be successful and a lot of it
is motion and all that and you're not
gonna have a lot of time for audibles
because of motion but also a lot of Kyle
Shanahan system is we're gonna give you
two plays and however they come out one
of these is going to work I'll give you
a decision tree basically but a lot of
what Aaron Rodgers said in the article
was about the two-minute drill because
Aaron would use a two-minute drill to
overcome Mike McCarthy so he wasn't just
using it at two minutes he'd be like
eleven minutes left in the first quarter
he's around the two-minute you're gonna
do the hurry up cuz I don't even want
your plays in the system right but like
we've said before when Aaron gets out
there and Davante Adams goes in motion
and then Jimmy grande slides across to
the left side and he looks up and he
goes holy [ __ ] it's exactly what we
wanted
that's when Aaron Rodgers is gonna buy
in but it's like saying right now that
Aaron Rodgers has been on Curb Your
Enthusiasm for 11 years and for 11 years
they said we want this scene to start
off at a and get to Z and how
over the [ __ ] you get there we trust you
and now he's got a new director that
goes
it's Seinfeld and you need to hit all of
your lines and he's going but I've won
like five Emmys by improvisational
acting and now I don't know if that
makes I went with you on the analogy I'm
just picturing like a slow camera pan in
on Mike McCarthy's face on the sidelines
as you hear boom boom boom it's like
he's got a great curse and it's like he
didn't call in the plays no but like you
know Aaron Rodgers has done one thing
really well and he's one of super
villain he's won MVPs and I can tell
while he's go I don't want that to be
lost but yeah that'd blow up on Friday
to read the article today if I'm a
Packers fan I'm very excite it's that
classic internet thing of yes headlines
are fun and yes pull quotes are fun but
like make sure to read the article out
there if you're ever gonna comment on
something there's nothing more annoying
than you know being in a bar argument
with someone and they clearly just read
the headline you actually read the the
summation lead with all the different
quotes then well for information for you
yeah that's why we have little big
offseason because we read the [ __ ] we
all be like the headlines
you know but it's really like so many of
the headlines or woe grabbers sure and
then when you read it it's the complete
opposite totally yeah
so that's what we're here to do is to
educate you guys so you don't get caught
in the whoa so you don't have to read
the article yourself so we are down to
the last one yeah which you came out
last week and said this is known as the
hammer and apparently listen to the pod
and a guy that I have never met but I've
always enjoyed his work and I don't even
know if I'm saying his last name right
John Bishara of WIP in Philadelphia sent
me a little thing especially for you Oh
so as we get to number one this is what
we got that's awesome so thank you John
Bishara
for doing that I'm gonna actually not
play that off my phone next time I'm
gonna do that to the other people but we
just got it so whoa the offseason in
burrs hammer he's the angry hammer in
burrs hab because I got to say like
pronouncing my last name correctly
you're like forever in my good book
because my whole life you know like the
telemarketers call mr. Engler
it's for some reason it's pretty simple
Thank You burr but thank you for getting
my last name correct I just like that
you have an audio drop oh my god I feel
they've been doing this for like three
times
that's better than if I got like a star
on the Walk of Fame I have a drop
that's uh what a day it's not gonna go
away all right so what's number one
number one is about Brian Flores this is
my favorite and I'm so happy see usually
I feel like you're looking at my notes
you you know what I'm about to do look
I'm just gonna share everything with the
homies I will send you ones but I don't
know the order that you're gonna put
them in and this is one that I kind of
asked her so we agree that it's great so
Brian Flores of the Dolphins amazing
coach 38 years old right man
he's like lost in the lake we all talk
about mcvade Shanahan he's about as
young as the rest of these guys has a
huge wallet practice that says TNT on it
if players make mistakes they run to the
wall and back
TNT stands for takes no talents okay so
here's what's awesome in the TNT there's
words like focus and and like energy and
all that stuff right but the reason he
says takes no talent and they gave an
example that like Josh rose and fumble
the snap Josh that takes no talent yeah
you can run to the wall run back the
things in this ESPN article as much as I
have been loving Vic Fangio I am going
all in on Brian Flores I am realizing
that I think that Brian Flores could be
the Shawn McVeigh of defense mm-hmm
that's where I'm going with this so much
so - he has these apparently he's been
showing up to media pressors seven
minutes early so not only his players
know that showing on time showing up on
time is late the media he said early is
on time on time is late and late is
forgotten
fucking-a put it into my veins he goes
is it a rule no it's my personal mantra
I have a lot of respect for time it's
precious we shouldn't take it for
granted this is a guy that came up 100
sent in Bella check system we've had no
power before he ever got to New England
he was like a linebackers coach then he
became like a defensive assistant then
the defensive coordinator he has been
groomed by Belichick and I truly believe
that when you look at Detroit and you
see Patricia and you have two defensive
players right now that are planning to
hold out but he was supposed to be
Belichick number one guy
but in Miami these guys are going man
that's just Flores he's crazy the
difference is is if you had a personal
trainer like Flores who's a jack 38 year
old oh and I said Patricia Patricia's
going work harder meanwhile fleurs is
going work harder and he's been at the
facility since for 30 days running steps
I wonder why they're questioning
Patricia and Detroit and they're
lockstep with Flores right now Miami hmm
I feel like this is gonna be the
Belichick protege where it works do you
think Flores is gonna call out any
reporters for slouching the way Patricia
did mm-hmm
I I don't think he will because I don't
think Flores cares right because fleurs
is going you're not on time like you're
gonna live your life that's fine I don't
have to worry about you oh so you're
either you're in Flores is good graces
or you're not and yeah moving on next
I think he's gonna look at reporters
with their slouch and he's gonna go that
takes no talent but he does that in his
head because I think he's gonna be
smarter with the media like Belichick he
has enough time for that in terms of the
whole talent thing he said he said it's
a focus issue it's a mindset issue we
try to make it emphasis on those things
things that take no talent I think those
are the details that help you win games
there's talk about focus and execution
and apparently he also walks around the
facility saying rent is due every day
like he is one of those like Instagram
focus well that's gonna say you know
what movie coach he reminds me of who
Denzel Washington from Remember the
Titans you fumble you run a mile you
miss a blocking assignment you run a
mile like that's literally what this guy
is doing I think that's what Brian
Flores is like I really do like I he
might be the Denzel what was that guy's
name he was coach Boone coach
that's so good I'm just letting you know
that if you as a Patriots fan I'm very
concerned because if you have a
disciplined Miami Dolphins team and we
all know that in like part Scott told us
like all these teams go to Miami and
they get drunk the night before and
Miami already has an advantage there I'm
very excited I'm just you got to see it
for a season that we've we've heard of a
lot of hard ass coaches come in Bill
Belichick was five and eleven his first
year in the Patriots camp and you know
they there was a lot of like talk of who
he's gonna clean house he's gonna be a
tough guy you got to see it on the field
there's a lot of times doc I'm buying
all of the stock that's fine by lo
you're like like Russell o Kuhn with his
crypto yeah yeah yeah yeah by lo all
right so those are whoa big offseason
enjoyed it a lot and as you continue to
see whoa big offseason send them to us
there's nothing I like more than opening
the left go show mentions and it's just
a lot of lobokoff seasons with a picture
of Phillip Rivers and a visor sure of
that ship I put out my rankings for top
stepdad rankings I factored in some of
the things that Kyle Brant told us yeah
if you haven't listened to the Kyle
Brant episode he had a lot of good
really like really cagey thoughts on
that he had a stepdad added so much
insight you have value added my top five
I went five Drew Brees for Cam Newton
three Nick Foles to Ryan Fitzpatrick one
Marcus Mariota and my bottom five a lot
of young guys Josh Allen try Biscay Joe
Flacco Baker Mayfield and last was ela
you just love putting Elena but I think
Eli has the the lowest warp in these
lists
absolutely he has had the steady low and
I only rank 30 of them and some people
got it and some people didn't fare hey
and I was good but for me I think I will
admit this I personally surprised myself
I did not expect to put Cam Newton that
high mm-hmm part of the reason I did was
I just started thinking about wearing
matching outfits with Cam Newton and him
like getting me a lot of swag and then I
also thought about if I was a kid and my
dad my stepdad was Cam Newton a lot
cooler people would come to the house
okay cuz like I wanted to factor that
into like Matt Ryan is not having the me
goes over but like at my 16th birthday
the me goes might perform if Cam
Newton's my step data so I that's why he
kind of Rose this is the crucial
question I was gonna ask you actually
right when you said we're ranking the
quarterbacks in terms of who could be
your stepdad is that me left goes
producer in his 30s right he's now
acquiring a stepped ahead at this stage
of my life I'm like well into my career
kind of thought about when I was doing
it all fact all stages of life or is it
me at like nine years old because if I'm
nine oh my god I want Baker Mayfield is
my stepdad is like oh my god he's gonna
have like cool parties and he's gonna
like show me the town but like he's
gonna put his arm around my mom all the
time but if it's like me and my thirties
like I kind of want like Drew Brees just
like a like a guy like I'm sure he drew
brees day number five because I just
thought that he would give me the good
discipline but also be cool and like his
son seemed cool like those kids running
around like I'm down to be the older
brother figure to those kids
I mean they might be like listen don't
listen to Adam I've taught you guys
enough don't listen to him but yeah that
would be cool so could I could I just
come in with a Cody your biggest gripes
so I always have to mention something
about Brady but Brady was way too high
on this list we wanted him you wanted
him at like nine I had of a nice seat to
me a really crucial step with with the
stepdad it's it's the way you think of
your uncle or your grandpa or whatever
that comes into town and is like your
mom won't let you have ice cream for
dinner but I will cuz I'm the cool uncle
right I'm the cool stepdad that's like
trying to buy you off with writing stuff
Brady would be like hey you can have
this raw kale and rhubarb like he would
not have some amazing snacks in the
pantry for it I thought about you know
what it's like to be connected to that
guy and and he is so famous so like what
that would do for you yeah that stuff I
really put them one slot over Russell
Wilson because I thought at the end of
the day even though they're both a
little crazy pants to me Tom Brady is a
little bit cooler genuinely than Russell
Wilson I interesting I don't know why
now the step up into Russell yeah Wow
thank you because Tom is gonna I like
the reason I think I moved Tom and Brees
higher than I thought I would originally
is I did go I mean if
was a kid I want to be disciplined a
little bit and so if I was raised by a
breeze or a Brady I feel like I would be
ready to kill the world
we appreciate the disciplinarians in
retrospect but fine picking my future
foe you know my stepfather like I'm not
gonna opt in to punish I know I want a
free-for-all I want think I had read
some stoic philosophy and I was like I
got like it got me in the mode all right
what other ones Derek Carr I just really
don't want to be on camera for the next
four months oh you don't want to be I
don't want to be in hard I don't want to
be some side character well had about 22
yeah I'm just saying like that to me is
dead last because I just don't want to
be on Hard Knocks because I don't know
how they'll portray me or you're afraid
that like and Derek cars steps up exist
and I'm moping in the water in his 30s
and he has a child of his own exactly
and I'm watching this at home and like
you know they caught me and they edit it
in a certain way and now my wife's mad
at me and I'm like I didn't I didn't
want any of this that's what Vic said to
Vic said that him and his wife did a
reality show
hmm and I said how long did it take and
he was like two months and I was like
would you ever do it again he goes
absolutely not it's a thing he goes you
have no control over the Edit and all of
a sudden the episode comes out and
they're focusing on one thing that you
had no idea oh yeah and the entire
episode is Michael Vick has a burping
out loud problem and he's like dude it's
side yeah so you know you've been in an
edit you know like what you can use
right now see not that anyone's ever out
to get somebody but you know the
capability that editors have with a room
full of footage and you can put this
little music sting on it and you can put
this little slo-mo down and you make it
look like this person's looking across
the room you cut away to this person and
they use a shot of me making a frowny
fin that's all you know like three hours
later but they put it there 100% yeah
yeah all right so you're afraid of hard
knocks I just don't want to be on it
because it's so out of my control
okay so yeah Derek Carr great guy I also
don't wanna live in Las Vegas so if he's
my stepdad like moving forward if I want
to visit my Vegas stepdads pretty funny
combination that's that's a great name
for like a Dennis Quaid life he has
lived off his strip David let's go to
the Golden Nugget are any other gripes
yeah Kyler Murray and Russell Wilson
they just seem like they'd be really
excited to like play catch in the
backyard a lot of these guys would Kyler
Murray with the baseball background he
like a nice like slider to show you yeah
I cried Kyler at 23 and Wilson at 10 I
really it's just about what you
prioritize and for me playing catch in
the backyard with my stepdad I wanted to
be as optimal a catch experience as
possible I hope these guys like I had
luck very high and then when I got done
he was at 11 because I kept thinking
about him with like overalls dropping me
off at school and me like don't forget
to tie your shoes me love you sang it
back like I just I started thinking
about that and like I thought about like
Carson Wentz being like a chaperone at
like a sophomore hop bands great yeah
but until he's like come and dance with
your dad don't be embarrassed it's love
and it's like no I just I thought about
public embarrassment and then what's
funny as I get into like this I got into
like a Matt Ryan Case Keenum right in
the middle where I was like they're kind
of good they're kind of whatever I had
mahomes at 16 I don't know why set dads
were hard it's it's a tough one and you
know what like it's up to you to to just
create your own criteria which is why we
have these lists it's it's to spark some
debate my favorite thing though is I had
I had one Seahawks fan right I cannot
believe that you have Russell Wilson
behind Tom Brady this list is stupid
they just get angry at that and I'm like
the list is stupid on purpose I'm
ranking quarterbacks his stepdads like
so many people get so hot and heated
about it and a lot of people are like I
appreciate the ones are like I don't
know what stepdad rankings means awesome
but the people that are just getting
angry cuz they just see a list of
quarterbacks and they just go Jared golf
is a lot better than my home's man I
love you guys they give me life they
just want to see rankings ranked whoever
created the idea of rankings for in
terms of sports media just like power
rankings and top five this and top 20
this just gave everyone hours and hours
and hours of enjoyment so thank you to
that person and you work there right now
welcome to bleacher guys thank you so
much I hope you enjoyed that with mr.
Michael Vick we are gonna try and get
him on soon he was awesome thank you to
you mr. in bur a burrs hammer
well I think we need to create a segment
of radio show bumps oh yeah yeah
a lot of like fart noises and if you
like if you like a podcast that punches
you in the face of booze listen to the
left go show guys we'll be back later
this week with another podcast I
appreciate you all so much
play that funky music as we get our way
out of here for David II more do you
have anything to say as we sign off just
a lot of love to the fathers out there
for Father's Day week oh yeah she got
anything good oh my god I got some new
kicks
did you know Oh baby all right to all
the dads whoa big dads season wheel
holla holla holla holla
[Music]